so let's just recap the uh Christian
pill guys um Chase and um a friend of
his um wanted to have a conversation
about some of the notes that I made um
on his Twitter space and I
mean I think that the underlying notion
of what the original scripture and most
religion says is generally pretty good
so I can be clear with that it was an
interesting talk
um I wanted to shut my mouth as much as
possible ask some questions and just
listen to what they had to say and um
you know follow up with the questions
with other questions I think the biggest
issues that I took with the whole
Christian pill and keep in mind these
guys aren't Catholic they're not uh
other denominations they are subscribers
to the Christ pill
um obey Jesus Christ and you will be
saved essentially was the Crux of most
of the message but I found listening to
the space that there's actually a lot of
disagreements in their space uh amongst
those that are trying to push the
Christian pill a lot of the solutions
that they offer um are not very good in
my opinion and they're flicking boogers
at the red at the red pill um I'm not a
big fan so let me be clear clear I'm not
a big fan of all of these different
pills of Association the orange pill the
green pill the white pill the red pill
the purple pill all of these pills to me
I spent time in the space I know many of
the creators very well I no longer
choose to collaborate with them which
I'll talk about in a little bit um I'll
let you know why I left and what I saw
um when we get into the Fatal flaws of
the red pill and the manosphere um but
these Christian pillar guys which are
bickering back and forth with the red
pillar guys on social media mostly on
Twitter X um the
main issue that they seem to take is
that it's uh degenerate uh you know
encouraging guys to avoid marriage um
stay away from women on a long-term
basis uh indulge in degeneracy
promiscuity things like that you know
they you know they complain that red
pillars are saying um you know they're
ta they're they're telling men to avoid
uh promiscuous women yet they're making
women you know promiscuous by indulging
in them so I think there's some
reasonable push back that they've made
but they keep going on about how their
Club is the best club and you know
there's nothing but degeneracy in the
red pill
uh and everybody should join their Club
but there's just as many flaws if not
many more um with the Christian pill um
there it relies on a lot of hope so
let's start with that it relies on the
hope that um if you marry a ho she's
going to have repented for her sins and
never go back to her old ways uh that if
you take vows before the church and God
that that will continue into perpetuity
and she'll will never change change her
mind about you if she believes strongly
enough in Christ and the Christ pill and
all that sort of stuff uh and of course
they talk about leading and being
masculine which are all really important
things too um but there's a lot of hope
that uh is out there and when I asked
them I think it was Chase uh that the
question came up and if you don't know
who he is he's The Sovereign bra guy
that's on whatever you can go back back
to last week's show I'm sure that you'll
recognize him if you've seen the
whatever podcast because he's out in
Santa Barbara area
um they they don't even know um what
laws are hostile towards men they just
say get married March March in the
marriage and go and do it and you know
grow up and be a man um is essentially
most of the message and I want to ask
them like you know do you understand why
there's problems and why laws need to be
reform reformed what laws should be
reformed what kind of Reform should
exist he didn't have any answers he's
like I truthfully don't know much about
divorce and divorce law um so it relies
on a lot of Hope let's just hope
everything works out and I've always
said hope is a terrible plan um it's not
what I recommend I think that you should
make informed decisions as a man I mean
that's what I do I'm I'm a generally
slightly older uh man than most of my
viewers I'm more of a seasoned fellow a
little bit of salt and pepper in life
and I've made some mistakes and I've
made some good choices as well and I
continue to make better choices or more
better more better is that even a thing
I continue to make more of more of my
choices tend to be better than worse
nowadays so I offer some of that wisdom
to you guys uh which is a I've provided
in the book and many of these podcasts
and interviews that I've done yada y
yada so yeah I didn't I didn't get a lot
of um I mean at the end they're all rich
or influenc so why don't you join our
club basically and I'm like I'm not
joining your Club it kind of sucks um
there's there's too many problems with
you know the Christian pill and it it
goes back to fixing the church first
again I said the original scripture
seems to be good uh and it seems to be a
pretty good set of rules uh but with all
the infighting and the the drama and oh
that's not a real Christian or that's
not a real Catholic or that's not a real
whatever um and the solutions they come
up with are just batshit crazy like uh
you know guy that was running a
Christian dating site uh match up uh
body counts of men and women so if he's
been with 10 then match her up with that
guy if she's been with 10 um it it
completely overlooks family law the need
for reform protection measures need to
be in in place um it's basically they
usually come up with um let's remove no
fault divorce which really changes
nothing it just it just makes it harder
for them to get divorce but it doesn't
change any of their underlying laws
which are problematic and hostile
towards uh men and more specifically
fathers where they get screwed uh the
today's church for them constantly uh
censors many of the original scriptures
for example um women must submit to
their men uh modern churches today are
uh censoring that phrase they're
modifying or trying to be more
Progressive or updating the language and
you know they're filled with mostly beta
males you know I said during the show
that it seems mostly to be a a beta
Factory and the women that are in those
spaces are either usually older women or
women that have made a whole ton of bad
choices in their youth you know in their
20s decided to get right with God go to
the church and now they're there uh with
three kids from three different fathers
in a body count of like you know dozens
now dozens upon dozens usually and the
church is saying you know wipe up these
hoes um the argument that I made on the
show that a lot of people didn't like
was you can go and put 200,000 km on a
car you can uh roll back the odometer to
zero you can punch out the dents clean
up the paint replace the carpets put new
ones in the car still has 200,000 km on
it you can Rebrand it and repaint it as
new it's still been used and had a whole
bunch of owners in it so I don't believe
the whole you know you can repent for
your sins for not being chased you know
before marriage and God will forgive you
sure maybe but she's still a hope uh
that car still has a whole bunch of
clicks on the clock even though you wind
it back to zero I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out